[Music]
many moons ago
a nameless evil was imprisoned in a
place far beyond reach
hurry up if he were ever to be released
it would spell certain doom for all
existence
[Music]
is that fear i smell
your planet will be torn to pieces and i
will we need your black screens
is this yours um
oh my god the gem of braxtonite
whoever wields it is able to command me
go over there
and wait first to come back in the
morning you will suffer an eternity for
this
[Music]
mom dad i want you to meet psycho gorman
or pg for shores i will bathe in your
blood
don't worry be worried
he's gonna kill everybody not unless i
tell him
[Music]
what did you three maniacs get up to um
this is getting a little
this sick game must come to an end
she will enslave the galaxy into endless
servitude
kill him cool
the ultimate evil has awoken
[Music]
there's a new god in town and his name
psycho gorman
it was nice meeting you it would be
nicer if you were dead
all right bye
[Music]
you